hi guys its Johanna here welcome to my
home a lot of you have been requesting
for an updated video on what I eat in a
day so today I'm gonna share with you on
what I really eat in a day so guys I do
eat rice on a daily basis and in fact
I've increased my rice intake I'm also
going to share with you how it has
helped me to increase my workout
performance reduce my body fat and also
increase my lean muscle mass so I'm
going to share with you what I eat for
breakfast lunch and also dinner nowadays
for breakfast I won't force myself to
eat breakfast so let's say if I'm not
feeling hungry in the morning then I
won't have breakfast however if I know
that I'll be having a busy day ahead and
I need lots of energy then I will make
myself a really simple breakfast I like
to keep it simple and quick so I will
have two soft-boiled eggs with a piece
of toast spread with peanut butter to
prep the eggs it's really simple I will
place two eggs in a pot and cover it
with boiling water and I will leave it
for five to ten minutes until it's done
for those of you who are Malaysians or
Singaporean so you will know exactly
what I mean this is actually our
favorite breakfast my breakfast is
really this simple to softball eggs
served with a piece of toast spread with
peanut butter so let me know in the
comments below if you do enjoy your eggs
this way as well
we like to cook our lunch in the morning
as well so that we can pack it and take
it out with us and I'm very lucky
because I have my boyfriend here to cook
lunch for me we're cooking pan-fried
salmon with chicken breast served with
white rice and also stir fried cabbage
so muscle man is just slicing the
chicken breast as well as salmon
[Music]
right are we ready to cook yes
choose to season your food with herbs
and spices as well as black pepper it's
the best way to add flavors to your food
without extra calories
I'm gonna cook enough rice for lunch and
dinner so usually it's about two small
cups and that's about 300 grams of
uncooked rice so this is not just for me
but it's for me as well as my partner
and personally I prefer basmati rice or
jasmine rice make sure to rinse your
rice okay so this is lunch 1 salmon
fillet which is about 120 grams after
cooked 1 bowl of rice as well as cabbage
I don't count my cabbage to be honest
the more vegetables you have the better
and why is it that I've started eating
more rice in nowadays firstly it builds
me up for much longer and it has given
me a lot more energy during my workout
as well that means I'm able to lift
heavier and I'm able to perform better
and as a result I've seen improvement in
terms of increasing my lean muscle mass
as well as reducing my body fat because
I don't crave as much anymore before
that when I used to be afraid of eating
rice and consuming less rice I used to
crave like let's say in the late
afternoon time and I used to just
randomly grab something just to fill me
up but since I've started increasing my
rice portion I don't have that cravings
anymore I personally prefer white rice
it's because it's easy on my digestion
so it's easier for my body to digest if
I were to consume too much of brown rice
it takes my body much longer to digest
and sometimes it can leave me feeling
bloated and one cup of white rice on one
cup of basmati rice has about 190
calories and about 40 grams of cups and
this amount is equivalent to two slices
of bread which has about 30 grams of
carbs and also about 190 calories or one
I would say small to medium potato
same calories same carbs but to be
honest I will not feel that satisfied if
I were to consume two slices of bread or
even one small sweet potato so that's
why I've decided to sort of like switch
my diet and consume more rice increase
my carb intake and I've seen results
over the past three months I have more
energy I perform better and most
importantly I am consuming less chunks
because I don't crave as much so what
I'm trying to say here is that rice is
not bad for you okay don't label rice as
something that oh you should not eat if
you want to lose weight but rather it's
about understanding food portion yes you
can include rice into your daily diet
but you need to understand how much rice
you need in order to let's say lose
weight gain weight or even to help to
improve your performance alright so I
would consume about one small bowl of
rice for lunch and another half to one
bowl of rice for dinner depending on how
intense my workout is before I pack this
into containers I have to make sure that
they're all fully cooked down to room
temperature then I'll pack them up and
bring them out with me to my video shoot
when it comes to meal prepping you want
to make sure that you separate each
ingredient so protein should be
separated from the vegetables and rice
by making it this way your food will
last longer when you take it out with
you okay so don't just mix everything
into one big containers and you want to
make sure that all the foods are fully
cooled down to room temperature before
closing them lunch is ready we've been
enjoying a lot more at dinners at home
nowadays and to be honest being at home
most of the time we like our dinners hot
so I'm going to prep big chicken and
tilapia with vegetables
Brussels sprouts carrots as well as
onion and I'm going to season it with
Cajun let's start by prepping the
vegetables
and don't forget your onion okay onion
makes everything more flavorful all
right now that all the vegetables are
ready we're going to place all the
ingredients into a baking tray and bake
it in the oven I'm going to drizzle with
a little bit of olive oil just very
little all over the chicken tilapia and
also vegetables and don't forget to
season your food season your food with
herbs and spices it is the best way to
add flavors to your food without the
excess calories so we love Cajun and
therefore we're just going to season it
with cajun spices okay you can be
generous if you want to and of course
black pepper
lots and lots of black pepper okay
yeah packing the flavors so I'm going to
cover this with aluminum foil and place
it in the other to cook for about 40
minutes long all right and make sure to
pop some holes for the heat to be
released when the meat and vegetables
are cooking all right
just small hosts okay and this is now
ready to go into the oven do you
remember the left over rice from lunch
so I'm going to make egg fried rice for
dinner
[Music]
dinner is ready big tilapia and chicken
with Brussels sprouts as well as carrot
and egg fried rice so don't worry guys
I am NOT eating all this on my own I'm
sharing this with my partner and I know
that he's always super hungry when he's
back from his workout and the reason why
I like to bake my food it's because it's
so simple all you have to do is put
everything together put it in the oven
for forty to forty minutes to one hour
and in the meantime you can go and get
on with other things and I like egg
fried rice okay it makes it more
interesting rather than just eating
plain white rice dinner is this simple
and I like to consider myself a lazy
chef if I can do this you can cook it as
well this is what I really eat in a day
as you can see I follow a balanced diet
this is about 40 percent cups 30 percent
protein and 30 percent of healthy fats
okay
as for snacks I like to either have a
small sweet potato or a handful of nuts
I love my nuts so I will have this as my
snack or sometimes even a protein shake
right after my workout session as well
as you guys can see I don't restrict my
diet I aim to eat some real food
wholesome food and food that will really
fill me up and I am not afraid to eat
rice
I do consume rice on a daily basis so
don't be afraid of rice okay most
important is for you to understand your
food portion and how much you need to
maintain a healthy weight do let me know
in the comments below if you enjoy this
video and if you want more meal prep
videos give this video a thumbs up share
this video on with a friends and do
check out other healthy recipes meal
prep videos on my youtube channel and
also exercise videos so guys stay active
on a daily basis in a well balanced diet
and stay safe all the best